who knew besides your agent who knew
that you were doing this i mean how hard
is that to keep it to like i mean it's
your family knew then my dad my brother
okay um and my and my mother at the time
and yeah just just kind of us
yup that right there is andrew garfield
admitting he lied to everyone but his
family about his super secret spider-man
no way home rule i still can't believe
it it happened the 38 year old actor
even lied to e.t the past year on more
than one occasion there's a lot of
chatter of the is he or isn't he when it
comes to the next spider-man
so let me just ask you i know what you
guys then i was like is he originally
what like what's the where's this going
well where is it going how do you tell
me there are rumors galore that you will
be in
spiderman no way um
oh boy listen what people are talking
about
is a really cool idea and and and again
i haven't received a phone call but now
the movie is out so when andrew visited
the ellen degeneres show he revealed how
many years he had to keep up the secret
how long did it take to make the movie
it was like a couple of years right how
many years did you lie to people
that's an unfair framework
it was uh yeah i lied to people for a
good two years and i lied to the
internet for two years and it felt great
and get this for the tick tick boom star
keeping the roll under wraps was
actually fun for him it was fun
to keep it secret because you know when
you're planning a surprise birthday
party for someone yeah and they're like
i hate surprises tell me is the party
happening so it felt like i was part of
organizing a surprise
birthday party for a bunch of people who
i knew would appreciate it andrew took
his spidey responsibility so seriously
he even lied to emma stone who played
his on-screen love interest gwen stacy
and is his ex-girlfriend emma kept on
texting me and she was like are you in
this new spider-man film
and i was like
i don't know what you're talking
what you're still walking out
she was like shut up just tell me i'm
like i honestly don't know what i kept
it going even with her
to the end you never admitted to emma no
and then she and then she saw it she was
like you're a jerk the oscar nominee
first played peter parker in 2012's the
amazing spider-man and reprised his role
for the film's 2014 sequel the amazing
spider-man 2.
should maybe uh consider coming in
through the lobby
also
my father is under the impression that
you require psychiatric attention all
right
peter
what happened what happened you should
see the other guy and now that fans have
seen him in the spidey suit once again
andrew feels a sense of relief and i'm
so happy that i get to talk about it now
here's what the actor told et about his
big return to the mcu and the fact that
i get to be one of those people wearing
the suit next to my actual spider-man
hero toby mcguire and
the the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spider-man of tom holland and
that i get to be the middle brother and
i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother and just like and
also there's something spiritual that
that kind of happened and happens and
that we were exploring in the film which
is like
you know archetypally the character is
so alone
the the isolation that that's a big
important part of the character in in
terms of the canon of spider-man for me
anyway and i think one of the reasons
why i think it's so appealing to so many
people around the world is that feeling
of
solitude that we can all
and loneliness
maybe is a better word that we can all
relate to and the question on everyone's
mind will andrew do it again you know
never say never i mean it's such it's
it's a character that's always gonna be
so meaningful to me and so beautiful to
me and i'm open
you